was so funny because i kept texting uh
chappelle like yo you're here
he's like yeah i'm here i'm in the hotel
i'm like good right yeah and i come up
the elevator and i go down the hallway
and i see chappelle
standing in the hallway with his
suitcase talking to
someone in the door like i'm like this
motherfucker's already talking to people
you know like like how social is this
[ __ ] guy right
and then i get close to the door and
it's malik just
just a boxer shorts in his gold chain in
his watch yeah man what time's the show
started i wanted to learn i never boxer
shorts gold chain in his watch i just
got him
i like how you call it his watch he
doesn't even give you the credit
what the heck
did you open up for somebody like that
um
my my favorite uh beast to open for
was cedric i always say this story
i always tell this story i say it all
the time it was uh
man let's let's i think my son was a
year old so then that was 16 years ago
and chappelle when i opened for
chappelle was uh
25 years ago and that was an amazing
thing like i was just like five years in
the game and here i am opening for him
at the house of blues
sold out and then here comes where
manila bay oh wow
and here comes dave walking in in a suit
and i'm just sitting there
i still smell like dolphin [ __ ] you know
i
mean
tour guide and uh and he just said i was
like yeah man like what's your name and
he
introduced myself and then uh he goes uh
oh because i used to open for these
headliners and they would get mad at
certain bits i would do
and then i told him i go hey i do like
these kind of this bit and that bit
and i go and a lot of headliners get mad
and he goes really
they get mad i go yeah he goes but then
they're not headliners
yeah he'd be correct that's five years
in like in the into my career you hear
that yeah and you know
i was just like happy i was opening for
people and like every time my headline
were like hey man you might want to stop
doing that bit
and do that you know that blah blah blah
like a rap and i would listen i'm like
okay yeah my bad just you know whatever
you want me to do i was just happy to
get on stage
then i told dave because i didn't want
to [ __ ] this opportunity up yeah i just
thought that's how headliners act
and then he was like really they're not
headlines that's hilarious
the headliner should be able to see
whoever's in front of them and then have
another
four or five hours to cover whatever it
is that they talked about like if you
cross yeah
you cross the same premise yeah i still
got two more hours some other [ __ ] that
they didn't talk about christ
yes that's a headliner and i swear to
god that was always my mentality after
that
yep i've always had that mentality with
him like i don't give a [ __ ] what you do
in front of me
and then uh then cedric is uh
i opened for him at the pochenga you
know it's like a big
yeah is that that's like down by i don't
know
yeah there's a huge like 3 000 people i
tell this story all the time because it
was like it was like
it was like an awe moment you know what
i mean because this is when i was like
i was doing closer close and close to
close the close-up like my whole routine
opening for people was just like
15 minutes of just applause breaks you
know i was just going for the jugular
you know what i mean
and with the whole like in my head i'm
like there's no way
anyone's following this [ __ ] like that
that was always my attitude right
and i said good night they're screaming
i i look to my left in my head i'm like
there ain't no way cedric's going to
fall this [ __ ]
but chang is going to hire me after this
[ __ ] right that's my [ __ ] yeah
and i look to my left and cedric is just
in this
[ __ ] outfit bro so same matching
fedora with the the
the jacket with the the vest matching
tie
ostrich yeah you know and then he's
bouncing like this he's like that's what
i'm talking about [ __ ]
for that money [ __ ]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen the entertainer and
i'm just standing on the side
as he walks out and literally like maybe
a minute into his act
i'm like these [ __ ] have
already forgotten
it was over man his intro was [ __ ]
you know that yeah because the intro was
fire
it never stopped it never stops i think
that's always been my mentality when i
have people open for me i'm like yo kill
it bring it
yeah that's different [ __ ] waves
exactly what you said to me
yep kill it kill it go out there and i
was doing all new [ __ ] all off the top
of my head i was like yo i'm
like freestyle this oh yeah dude he
rolled out there every night
right he had nothing new [ __ ] nothing
hour and a half and i'm just like
professional man i mean he's one of the
top 20 comments
i think it's weird too like we were just
in tampa
chappelle didn't come but malik and i
were in tampa and i have
guys my first friends i'm in comedy
outside la are in tan are in
florida miami nice ricky cruz and uh
luis uh what's his last name crew luis
or something
louis yeah thank you man luis yeah we
just all
enjoyed it yes luis diaz lewis christ
louise thank you man
thanks for the assist
[Applause]
and uh after the weekend both are like
man thanks for being so nice to us and
i'm like who the [ __ ] is that nice yeah
dude we there's some people we open up
for they wouldn't let us in the green
room
and we can't even talk to them what is
it like like we just hang outside of the
green room i'm like who the [ __ ]
they told me the guy's names i'm not to
say him but like we can't
we yeah they're like we i can't even we
can't my conversation
and he was a one guy was one of my
heroes and i was like yeah so i won't
talk to him is it cool if i get a
picture afterwards and the manager's
like no
he wants nothing to do with you like
just do your job
get out like what the [ __ ] wrong with
these people i don't understand that
dude i don't get it either
it's one of the greatest things is
talking to the comments no [ __ ] talking
about the road
and enjoying that moment yeah all the
laughs you're not even in the moment
yeah you're not even in the moment if
you're doing that you're literally just
doing it as
as if you're clocking in at a at a
regular
job like you'll meet them in miami
they're they're okay
monsters yeah that's crazy not weird
yeah
i don't like hearing stories like that
i've met a couple comics some of my
heroes
i've heard stories like that though
where they're just straight up like yeah
you can't come in even joe let me in the
green room i didn't want to
yeah phoenix the watch got you in though
baby i don't know yeah remember
it was also black history month so
[Laughter]
any other
thank you to our sponsors
we got these shirts rags man
cheesecake it's the brand baby it's like
starting out with the jameson joe you
know what to do with your feet
he's got slogans it's not a brand it's a
vibe
what the [ __ ] did you just say bro what
the [ __ ] did malek just say
he goes out of here it's not even
anything
man you guys know me it ain't a brand
new
get your merch i went from pushing mobs
to owning mom
good night like he ended every show like
that
we love you baby we love you
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son